as it is obviously India's destiny that
recovery by the whole infrastructure the
whole culture the whole development we
have seen in India three distance and
yeah they become that's what wrong but I
think it is for the Indians to start
believing in yourself in believing that
they can not only get India right but
help India contribute to getting the
world right I've been getting involved
in issues of climate change getting
involved in sure the poverty give many
of all the issues of governance at the
global network are the news will
demonstrate India's leadership role in a
multiplicity of areas and give birth to
the superpower of India